[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world so as you might know for
those that are supporting me on patreon
there's the possibility I'm going to put
the possibility up once in a while to
vote on the subjects that you want to
hear from and so I put up a vote about
it a few weeks ago and the two top
things that came up were the symbolism
of trees and also an interpretation of
Bladerunner 2049 so the interpretation
of Bladerunner is in the works work it's
being edited right now and so I wanted
to do this interpretation of trees they
this video about trees was proposed by
Shane Patton and I wanted to mention his
name because he's been a great supporter
of my art and of these videos and so I'm
happy that it's his question that got
voted up so that we can do it now to
understand the symbolism of the tree you
really need to understand more
encompassing symbolism and so as I
discussed the tree I'm going to join
other symbols together so that you can
really get a sense of a cosmic vision of
how the tree fits into a cosmic image
okay now as usual if you really want to
understand biblical symbolism you have
to start in Genesis and ideally you have
to start in the creation story now a
tree is an image of order it's an image
of hierarchy okay it's an image of how
things come together towards one so you
can imagine the trunk of a tree as a
kind of axis and then you can imagine
the branches of the tree as the
repeating pattern of the tree so a tree
is the branch of a tree has the same
structure of a tree and as the branch
separates into smaller into smaller
branches the same structure appears on
the tree as the basic tree in itself
okay and so it is a name
of this cosmic connection of everything
together okay so it is an image of order
now the idea of the tree can be order as
it comes towards one but it can also be
order as it separates into the many okay
now to understand the basic idea of the
tree we look at the story in Genesis now
we're used to thinking that in the
Garden of Eden
there was a tree but in fact there were
two trees in the Garden of Eden okay
there was the Tree of Life and the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil but
that's actually wrong there in the
creation in the story of Adam in the
Garden of Eden
there isn't two trees there are three
trees okay and the third tree is the fig
tree okay because when Adam and Eve fall
they make clothing out of the fig leaves
okay so now what you have to imagine if
you want to understand it this is this
is presented in in this book I told you
about this book so people have been
asking for reading list on symbolism
this definitely everybody needs to read
okay this is the hymns on paradise by
Saint Ephrem the Syrian and you have to
read the the introduction by Sebastian
Brock which is very excellent because he
crosses through the hymns and discusses
other texts by San Ephraim and the
interpretation of the Bible of the
Syrian fathers so the way it's presented
is that you have imagined paradise as a
mountain okay so where some people
aren't used to imagining paradise as a
mountain
but it makes absolute sense even in the
Bible it is suggested that the paradise
is a mountain though it's not said
explicitly in tradition it is said
explicitly that paradise is a mountain
and the way it's suggested in the Bible
is that it says that four rivers flow
out of the garden and go out in two
different directions and so just
actually in terms of phenomenology you
have to imagine the four rivers being
from starting at a higher point and then
moving out towards the world so a way to
imagine it is that the Garden of Eden is
actually the highest place in the world
it is the highest mountain and from the
top of the highest mountain comes this
these four streams that then come down
and water the entire world okay so you
have to imagine at the middle of at the
top of the mountain there is a tree and
it's the tree of life it's the axis of
the world it's the the the place where
all life comes together and this notion
that if you eat the tree of life then
you have eternal life
now imagine that now the garden in Saint
Ephrem vision is separated in two
sections so you have the tree at the
summit and then at a lower level on the
mountain there's another tree which is
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil okay and so the the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil you could see
it as the place where order begins to
separate in two opposites right you saw
a way to imagine it would be that you
have the the Tree of Life up there and
then the tree of knowledge of good and
evil and according to Saint Ephrem the
way it works is that Adam and Eve were
placed in the garden they were told not
to eat of the fruit of the tree of
knowledge and good and evil but the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil
actually acted as a kind of barrier like
in the temple a barrier towards the most
holy place the highest place the place
where everything totally comes together
which is the Tree of Life and so what
Saint Ephrem says and this is not just
in Saint Ephrem but it's actually
repeated in sand Irenaeus for example
and and in in some of the Cappadocia
father's and in Jewish tradition that in
fact if Adam and Eve had obeyed the
commandment of God to not eat the tree
God would have eventually given them the
fruit
so that they could then ascend towards
the The Tree of Life and so you can
imagine this tree of good and evil as a
test for whether or not Adam and Eve
will do it we'll do it by disobeying out
of their own volition or by submitting
to the higher authority by submitting to
the transcendent rule would then have
access to the higher mystery okay so
imagine now the tree of the Tree of Life
in the center as this one axis then the
tree of the good and evil as the place
where things start to separate and I
imagine the mountain is getting wider
and then at the bottom of the mountain
you have the wall of the garden which
acts as the limit of the garden and
there you have the fig tree and so there
the Adam and Eve take the leaves of the
fig tree and cover themselves with them
so you can see how as they move down the
mountain from the tree of knowledge of
good and evil they also coming near the
wall which covers the garden then they
have to cover themselves to hide there
let's say their nakedness they hide the
higher part the hide their mystery let's
say okay and be covered in mystery just
as I as they move away from the higher
tree they can know they can see less and
less the higher tree just as it you can
imagine for example in the temple you
have these series of veils and as you
move out from the Holy of Holies each
veil becomes more and more opaque as you
move towards the covering that is
outside the veil okay outside the temple
so these three trees now so you can
imagine them almost like one tree as the
entrance a second tree as the second
let's say place where everything is
divided and then the top tree which is
the place where everything comes
together but then there there actually
isn't three trees in the story of Adam
and Eve in the garden there are actually
four trees in the story of
and the fourth tree is a thorn tree or a
thorn bush it's the idea that trees will
produce thorns okay
and so you can imagine now on the
outside of the wall of the garden
outside of the inner holy place you have
these thorns which are to protect the
tree from attack so you have a world of
hostility which is outside the garden
and so the thorns need to be protected
okay so that's let's say the way that
it's presented in Saint Ephrem the
Syrian and so once you see how that
structure comes together you can you can
remember some parts in the Bible which
are surprising to some like for example
when Christ in the New Testament at some
point he curses a fig tree and you think
why is Christ cursing a fig tree well
sin Ephraim connects Christ's cursing of
the fig tree to let's say taking away
the power of the covering taking away
the power of this covering by which we
are removed from the most of the more
holy places just like the death and the
death of Christ split the veil in the
temple so to in Christ curses the fig
tree he removes the coverings as he he
brings men closer and closer to the
mysterious unity which is at the summit
of the of the of the mountain okay so
you can see it as these four trees but
you could also see it as one tree you
could see this notion that there's that
there is one tree the axis of the tree
is the Tree of Life you can see the
branches of the tree as the the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil the
leaves of the tree as the fig tree and
then the thorns on the tree are the last
protection of the tree as being the
thorn bush and you could also see the
tree as the mountain itself
as paradise itself as you move from the
oneness of the summit on the mountain
and you come down to find multiplicity
and as you come down towards the
wilderness that is down at the bottom
and you you come finally to the the
world of hostility of war of conflict
and then even further than that you
would have the flood you would have the
waters the ocean which surround the the
mountain of paradise surround the
mountain of the world that is the the
image of the cosmos really and so you'll
see if you read San Ephraim you're all
you'll also find that this mountain as
its described by Saint Ephrem he seems
to on purpose gives descriptions of it
which which place it outside of normal
time and space and so he'll say things
like the base of the mountain of
paradise goes beyond the the the
physical ocean view beyond Oceanos which
which surrounds the the known world and
so you have this idea that actually the
entire world as we know it is contained
within this hierarchical structure of
the Garden of Eden you know from the
gate to the Tree of Knowledge to the
Tree of Life ok now this notion of this
hierarchy the tree as this hierarchy as
bringing order to the potentiality which
is further down let's say in the waters
of the of the of the ocean and now
imagine at the top of the tree you have
you can you can kind of see it let's say
the source which is coming from under
the tree to imagine the tree really at
the top of the mountain and these four
sources like the four directions which
move out from the the central tree and
then go out into the world and then go
all the way into meeting with the ocean
and so just in terms of understanding
normal cosmology you can understand that
fresh water comes from above
fresh water always moves down okay and
so even if there's a source in the
ground you know that that source is
higher than the ocean okay
and so the the fresh water just like
rain falls on the mountain fresh water
moves away from this hierarchical
mountain then moves out towards the
towards the the outer waters the waters
of chaos the salt waters now and so in
that way there's a relationship between
the tree the hierarchy and this bringing
of fresh water towards or this
transforming of of let's say salt water
into fresh water and so I I'm saying
this because in the Bible you'll see
several places where this relationship
takes form so for example Moses will hit
a stone hit this you can imagine the
stone as a miniature version of the
mountain and then out of the stone comes
water which comes down and then the
Israelites can drink it so you can
imagine with the tree the tree hitting
the mountain this hierarchy making water
come down and flowing down the rock to
to to water to give water to the Israel
to the Israelites imagine another story
they find a puddle of bitter water so
now when you read bitter waters you can
imagine it as salt waters for example so
the Israelites they they find this
bitter water they can't drink that then
in the middle of the desert and so so
Moses takes a tree takes a you know a
rod a wooden rod and puts it down into
the water and transforms the WHA the
salt water into the bitter waters into
sweet waters into fresh waters okay
so the same symbolism repeating itself
again okay and so you can see it in
other ways for example the same image a
little different but it's the same idea
you can imagine the the tree as
separating the waters to you know
separating the waters just
in the beginning in the beginning you
can imagine God separating the water so
you have to always think in terms of
phenomenology you have the clouds up
above you have the water down below and
the things that go up into the into the
heavens which connects heaven and earth
are trees okay in the natural world and
mountains and so you can imagine Moses
hitting the waters of the Red Sea and
separating the waters like God separated
the waters at the beginning but also
this idea of the tree is acting as a
measurement of order between the the two
extremes of chaos okay now so there are
many there are many many other examples
for example you can see the same thing
when they create when they create the
bronze serpent is Paul acting like this
tree the those snakes at the bottom are
like the chaotic waters and then you
separate the waters you take one snake
that's made he makes a snake out of
bronze and puts it at the top of the
pillar the top of the tree the top of
the of the stick so that now the waters
are separated and in between there's a
place for order and you're not just
completely submerged in chaos okay there
okay so there are plenty plenty examples
but what's interesting I could just keep
going on with this but what's really
important to see is when you have to
come to Christ you have to come to
Christ and so in the tradition there are
many hints that hints that help us to
link this idea of the trees in the
Garden of Eden with the cross of Christ
now it's already there in the story for
those who can see it but there are many
little traditions that can help us to
make sense of it and help us put the
puzzle together for example there are
traditions which say that the cross of
that the Tree of Life or the tree of
good and evil there are different
traditions on that will the the wood of
that tree will have been take
to make the staff of Moses will have
been taken to make the pillar for the
bronze serpent and then that piece of
wood would continue down on the line to
finally become the cross itself and our
traditions would say that for example
the axis of the cross was made out of
the Tree of Life and the the horizontal
of the cross was made by with the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil and
you can see in the story of the
crucifixion you have the three crosses
which emphasize this this this
centrality and duality with the Good
Thief on one side of Christ and the bad
thief on the other side of Christ
representing this notion of good and
evil as the two branches of the cross
let's say or three crosses it doesn't
really matter how you see it it has the
same idea of this central thing and then
two things on the side and also in the
story of the crucifixion Christ has the
thorns that thorn bush which was outside
of the garden that thorn bush is then
put on Christ's head when you when you
start to think about the crucifixion you
you use your mind starts to play tricks
on you because that story is very
difficult to understand it's very
difficult to encompass all the mystery
that is contained in the story of the
crucifixion but Christ takes the lowest
thing the lowest thing on on the story
of the mountain these thorns that are
outside to protect them and he changes
them into a crown and so the lowest
becomes the highest and then he is
nailed fixed on to this hierarchy on to
both the Tree of Life
and the tree of good and evil with the
crown of thorns and then as he is on the
cross the Roman soldier pierces his side
and out of his side comes blood but also
comes water and this water comes down
and the blood comes down and so you have
this crazy image which repeats actually
this story from the beginning of of the
Bible that Christ on the cross is not
just the tree of life not just that you
have good and evil
not just the thorn bush not just a
mountain he's all those things all
together at the same time and he's also
the water which flows down and reaches
out into the world and in early
Christian images they explicitly showed
the cross with the four sources of
paradise at the feet of the cross and so
that's enough said about that but I just
wanted to show you how that image of the
tree in the crucifixion takes up its
highest form and and just and and and
the Christ its relationship to that tree
creates an image which is it's just it
blows your mind you can't really
understand because he also dies on the
tree he also dies on the tree in the way
that God told Adam that he would die if
he eats of that fruit so Christ eats the
fruit of the knowledge of good and evil
and has access then to the Tree of Life
and you can see that that's the case
they showed in the text because when he
dies the the the the veil of the temple
the the veil the holy of holies is
ripped into two and so is this idea that
Christ enters into the highest place
it's the fruit of the good and evil like
sin Ephraim says as a way to enter into
the holy of holies which is the tree of
life itself
and so finally just to bring everything
together you have to come toward to the
end of the Bible where in the final
revelation of the entire cosmos you have
a cube a cube which is the final form
the state of the static form of
everything that can be revealed and in
the middle of this cube is the Tree of
Life and you can also imagine this Tree
of Life and and the rivers flowing out
and filling up this New Jerusalem which
is perfect and made of a perfect
material and so there's this site this
notion of a final manifestation of
everything from the beginning until the
end into one you know into one
impossible but you know eschatological
manifestation and so yeah I went a lot
further with you guys than I ever have
in this stuff so I hope I hope it wasn't
too obscure if it was give me some
comments tell me what you think and I'll
see if I can maybe try to answer some
questions in the in the question section
so I hope you enjoyed it and talk to you
soon